[Música]
en córdoba en el 2020 se quemaron
alrededor de trescientas 40.000
hectáreas lo que equivale a casi medio
millón de cancha de fútbol profesional
mi nombre es tamara y hace 13 años que
soy bombero voluntario de la provincia
de córdoba el año pasado junto con mis
compañeros estuvimos trabajando
alrededor de tres meses
incansablemente para sofocar las llamas
en medio de uno de esos incendios uno
que hacía ya varios días veníamos
trabajando el fuego estaba llevando un
lugar donde no tenía que pasar era un
barrio muy humilde yo estaba muy cansada
realmente estaba muy cansada y ya no
quería seguir
en eso soy un nene al patio de su casa
pequeñito de no más de cinco añitos con
una felicidad y eso me hizo pensar
su alegría de vernos ahí a pesar de que
algo malo pasaba
ilusionada que el niño que me llamó
héroe me dio la fuerza necesario para
continuar
a veces son mujer o es a los ojos de la
persona que en ese momento nos necesita
porque sabes que hacemos hasta lo
imposible para que en unos de sus peores
momentos tenga en quien confiar una
razón por la que creer algo por lo que
seguir a veces somos las peores personas
porque estuvimos en este momento no
siempre somos héroes no siempre podemos
salvar vidas y eso también nos duele
yo conozco de tener los dedos arrugados
por el frío y el agua conozco de la
temperatura del fuego te estilo de la
piel conozco ese pitido que me avisa que
mi tubo se está quedando sin aire
conozco la diferencia inter y sangre
arterial o venosa sin importar el
escenario el salir corriendo con 10
kilos de equipamiento de más
conozco cuando el día se vuelve noche y
hay que dormir en la chata sin importar
la hora un ratito y es seguir pero
créame que no somos héroes y lo siento
en los ojos de mamá cada vez que
regresamos puedo sentir su preocupación
en cada mensajito que me manda lo siento
cuando mi cuerpo llega a su límite y te
dice ya no más
mucha gente nos pregunta por qué por qué
arriesgar tu vida por alguien que no
conoces porque trabajan gratis
porque pasar tantas noches sin dormir si
solo es un árbol y bueno tienen razón
pero esa felicidad que nos regala a los
ojos de alguien en que ayudamos el hecho
de salvar una vida es realmente
impagable y eso nada ni nadie te lo
quita muchas veces cuando vuelve a dar
un siniestro
accidente rescate incendio
me pregunto por qué hay muchos de los
que volví pero no sé si volví del todo
una parte mía se quedó allá en ese lugar
tan triste al que tanta falta le
hacíamos los bomberos en ese animal que
vio en un incendio jugador destruido o
en el que fue atrapado por las llamas y
ya no pudo escapar a donde veíamos era
fuego el aire caliente te roba el poco
oxígeno y ya no podíamos respirar
a pesar de eso seguimos peleando contra
la bestia idol y ver como paso a paso
todo lo destruye y no logramos frenar
las
volví porque siempre vuelvo después de
algún incendio duro me replanteo si voy
a querer ir el próximo y siempre la
respuesta es sí por más difícil que haya
sido siempre vamos a volver bien sabemos
que del otro lado alguien nos necesita
alguien nos espera y por más duro que
sea siempre siempre vamos a volver no
somos héroes pero nosotros podemos ser
la diferencia entre que alguien vuelva a
casa o no en que se dé ese beso que se
dejó para después en que en esa mesa no
hay esa silla vacía
somos unos locos que nuestro único
propósito es cuidar la vida en todos sus
aspectos cuidar al ser humano al medio
ambiente el agua el aire la tierra misma
vivimos el cambio climático en cada
inundación en cada incendio forestal que
son cada vez más difíciles ver casas
destruidas en segundos el viento
arrasador los tornados de fuego las
nubes de fuego en cada desastre natural
que intentamos contener a veces sin
esfuerzo los sentimos sabemos lo que se
siente luchar y perderlo todo luchar y
no ver cambios porque el cambio se hace
antes según datos de la conae desde la
década de los 80 llevan quemadas
1.6 millones de hectáreas con más de 9
mil focos sólo en córdoba
todavía estamos a tiempo de frenar este
devastador futuro
yo les prometo que los bomberos siempre
vamos a volver por más difícil que sea
me importa lo que tengamos que
sacrificar así tengamos que abandonar
nuestras familias a pesar del frío el
hambre el cansancio el dormir mal
siempre vamos a volver pero solos no
podemos
el 99 por ciento de los incendios
forestales el responsable es el hombre
por negligencia por descuido o
simplemente por desinterés son
intencionales y son prevenibles
nosotros hacemos la parte de la
prevención pero si vos tiras colillas
prende fuegos sabiendo que algo puede
pasar lo haces por negligencia qué pasa
si alguien va a tu casa y le prende
fuego voy a tu living y te prendo fuego
las cortinas y no me importa nada voy a
toda empresa familiar que te costó 30
años construir y lo perdés todo porque
eso es lo que vos estás haciendo estás
prendido fuego mi casa algo que vengo
cuidando a todo pulmón desde hace años y
repito no somos héroes porque la
naturaleza no es un lugar para visitar
es nuestro hogar y tenemos que cuidarlo
y ojo esto no es una invitación es un
llamado a tomar conciencia y vos qué
vas a hacer
[Música]